et maintenant mesdames messieurs en
exclusivité mondiale la toute première
interview de jean marc c'est un scoop
sept à huit
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle jean marc c'est un jeune
singe au poil marron il triomphe depuis
quelques années en compagnie de jeff and
actor qu'ensemble ils composent lundi
duos les plus comiques de la télévision
rencontre avec un petit animal qui n'a
pas sa langue dans la poche
alors jean marc
disait le célèbre partenaires de jeff
pana clock cet homme qui a su renouveler
la ventriloquie en france vous êtes
rencontrés comment avec jeff non au
début il a commencé les cartes dauphin
n'ayez trop d'humidité sa guise et tout
le temps donc du coup il a essayé avec
un enfant né il a eu des ennuis avec la
justice
alors le courant est passé immédiatement
il faut dire qu'il est électricien à
l'époque hôpitaux d'agen et on sait
écrire des sketches
aux roses ou qu'il est éteint à 100 il y
aurait eu un mur entre nous
alors on est dû il ya eu des galères
mais très vite première télévision
premier succès mais qu'est ce qui fait
que tout à coup ce genre de spectacle
plaît pas parce que je suis drôle si tu
as d'autres questions qu'on tue et on
attendait ça
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui se sont
vexés de votre franchise ouais mais je
crois qu'ils sont alors maintenant
on sent que souvent votre partenaire
jeff gênés par ce que vous dites comment
vous entendez tous les deux avec les
oreilles
contre 100 en retrait et vous laissent
beaucoup dans la lumière ou pas ça qui
n'en souffrira un jour à il en souffrait
déjà entaché sa gueule
est-ce que vous pensez que sans vous
jeff fan club pour être drôle
évidemment que non
et vous semblez vous le seriez encore
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu